Happen,
the Joe Rogan experience and our fears
that you were just discussing earlier
about how soft we are in comparison to
the past civilizations in terms of like
our ability to live off the land.
That's one aspect that bothers me,
but one of the big ones that bothers me
is the fact that everything is digital.
All of our information is stored on hard
drives. You Bet. And if that goes down,
there's not much left. You've
paper books and, and you know,
a few thousands of years,
imagine what will be left. Yeah,
we would lose all of our advancement.
Well, I can, I can speak to this
at, at uh, at, at a personal level,
there was a time when I
was an excellent map redo.
I could navigate anywhere
with, with maps, you know,
my wife Santha an I did huge Jenny's in
Mexico back in the early 1990s in really
cheap hire cars with maps and we found
our way everywhere without any problem
today I can hardly use a map.
The skill of using a map has lapsed
within me. Why? Because of GPS,
GPS technology has come along and it's,
and it,
it always tells me where I
am and being a bit lazy, uh,
I just accept that, that technology,
but then I had caused to us myself,
there's just the other day supposing gps,
supposing all the satellites go down
and there's no, no gps is the whole,
the whole industrialized human
race is going to suddenly be lost.
All those Uber drivers who don't know
their way from a to B and who rely
entirely on their gps is they won't know.
They won't know where they're going.
And it's, and it's true with digital
data. The digital digital data,
unlike unlike print data is very fragile
and requires programs in order to
access and interpret it that are much
more complicated than simply cracking the
code of a,
a lost language.
Do you don't mean their programs vary
between different phone platform? Exactly.
Very computer platforms. It's
just, it's so fragile and it's so,
uh,
I mean,
I don't know if there's any precautions
that have been taken place to preserve
this information in case of like what
Robert Schoch describes coronal mass
ejection or something,
then click down all the satellites.
Yeah. No, I don't think,
I don't think preparation has been
made and I don't, and I don't,
and it's very clear that that preparation
is not being made for the risk of
another, a cosmic impact.
Um, uh, and again, a,
a point that I'd like to make
about this is that we are at,
we are in a sense in a place where
history can repeat itself, uh,
that there are certain cycles at work.
Uh,
the work on the comet impact 12,000,
800 years ago.
How has very clearly and specifically
identified the debris trail at that
comment.
And that Debbie trail is the Taurid
meteor stream and it's called the Taurid
meteor stream because it
appears to emanate from the
region of the sky in which
the constellation of Taurus sits. It
doesn't, it's within our solar system.
It's an optical illusion.
The Taurid stream is a
giant complex of debris.
Uh,
it is 30 million kilometers wide.
What you had was an original comment
that might have been a hundred to 200
kilometers in diameter,
a small moon which fragmented
and broke up into multiple,
multiple parts and those parts began to
spread out along the whole orbit of the
Taurid meteor stream.
And to widen the whole thing widens.
So it's like a giant tube of debris and
the evidence and the argument is that
12,000,
800 years ago,
several large bits of that debris fell
out of the Taurid meteor stream and
impacted with the earth.
The problem is that the tour of meteor
stream still exists and our planets still
passes through it twice a year.
Uh,
and those passages take place in June
and in November and each passage takes 12
and a half days and the same
group of scientists who are,
who are looking at the evidence for
the impacts 12,800 years ago are deeply
concerned that we may face future
impacts from the tour of meteor stream.
That there are still large objects up
there. This is not theory. This is a fact.
There's a comet up there,
uh, called comet Encke,
which is part of the Taurid meteor stream.
It's a large fragment of the
original giant comment comment.
Danky has a diameter of, I dunno, five
or five or six kilometers. There's,
there's 19 recognized huge objects within
the Taurid meteor stream calculations
indicate that there may be as much as
200 asteroids within the Taurid meteor
stream of a diameter
of a kilometer or more,
which would have
catastrophic effect if they,
if they hit the earth and responsible
astronomers regard the Taurid meteor
stream as the greatest collision hazard
facing mankind at the present time.
And it's not something that we need to
fall into despair about because it's
perfectly within the level of our
technology to do something about it.
What could they do? Well,
to give you an example,
a commercial interests are looking right
now and the technology is there to mine
asteroids. We can go to asteroids. If the,
if the commercial interest is high enough,
we can go to them, we can mine them,
we can extract minerals,
we can bring them back to the earth.
The same technology would allow you
to move asteroids or comet fragments.
You don't want to blow
them up with a nuke.
That would be a really bad idea
that would, that would, uh,
turn one large object into
multiple smaller objects,
which could cause equally massive
devastation and would be very difficult to
predict where that
devastation was going to fall.
What you want to do is to nudge them
and moved them out of a dangerous orbit
into, into a less
dangerous orbit. And, and,
and the evidence is in the next 30 years,
we are going to be passing through
dangerous filaments of the Taurid meteor
stream.
And if we were smart,
we would be devoting some resources
to protecting our cosmic environment.
Just as we, there are many issues
that we need to devote resources to.
Unfortunately,
the one that's most attractive to our
politicians at the moment is warfare. Uh,
we devote limitless resources to
technologies of mass destruction.
There.
There really is no end to the amount
that we're prepared to spend on that in
terms of our so called security.
We feel somehow we're making ourselves
more secure by having these incredible
weapons and spending
trillions of dollars on them.
But the cosmos doesn't give
a fuck about any of that.
The Cosmos is out there with these,
with these giant giant objects, uh,
which have a far greater explosive
power than all the nuclear, um,
weapons stored on earth at the,
at the present time, the comments,
you shoemaker levy nine which hit
Jupiter in 1994 had a total calculated
explosive power of 300 gigatons.
If you took the entire nuclear arsenal
of the world today and blew it all up at
once,
it would yield 6.4 gigatons.
So these objects are producing
catastrophic results on a scale that far,
far beyond anything that we ourselves
could do with nuclear weapons.
It's time we spent a bit less time and
money on weapons of mass destruction and
a bit more on looking after this
beautiful garden that we call the earth.
And that is our home and it will be the
home of our children and our children's
children. I'm a grandfather now.
I feel passionately about this.
We need to look after this planet.
It's our responsibility as a human species
to do so. And one of the challenges,
it's not the only challenge. There
are many, many other challenges.
One of the challenges is to pay attention
to our cosmic environment and to
realize that the cosmos can intervene
cataclysmically in the human story.
And that the tour of meteor stream in
particular may have been a hidden hand in
human history that there may have been
other impacts in the last 13,000 years
that affect have affected and changed
the course of humanity on this earth.
And the ancients were very good
at paying attention to the sky.
We ourselves have amazing
tech to study the sky,
but for some reason were ignoring
this problem of cosmic impact.
And that's incredibly irresponsible
because as I said a moment ago,
it is a solvable problem.
It is within the limits of our technology.
It would require a global cooperative
effort to sweep our cosmic environment
clean.
But it could be done and a side product
of that global corporation might be a
friendlier, more nurturing, more
loving, more positive human community.
It is very odd that we have
this infant town nature,
even as grown adults and
world leaders that we don't,
we do like to nor imminent danger as long
as it hasn't effected us in the past.
Yes,
there's no real moment we can point to
other than tongue goose SCA in you know,
photographic history,
modern history where you
could take pictures of things
when we had an agenda and
if I can,
if I can pause you on that very point.
The evidence is compelling that the
Tunguska event was an object that fell out
of the Taurid meteor stream that
happened at the peak of the Bita tour.
It's in June,
1900 and eight that it's extremely likely
that that Tunguska object came from
the Taurid meteor stream because we
were passing through the Taurid meteor
stream at exactly that time.
And what are the tongue Glusker?
Object is estimated to be between
60 and 190 meters in diameter.
So it's not a very big object. It's not
a kilometer scale object. It's a, it's,
it's, it's big, but it's not that big.
It doesn't even hit the earth. It,
it's an air burst.
It explodes in the sky above fortunately,
and uninhabited area of Siberia.
But the devastation is huge.
It wasn't even noticed for some years
afterwards until scientific teams went in
and studied the area and discovered
that 80 million trees across 2000 square
kilometers had been completely
flattened by that airburst. Uh,
and to put that in context, 2000 square
kilometers is the size of London.
So anybody who knows London is aware
that there's a ring road around London
called the m 25 if that air best
had taken place over central London,
everything of London out as far as the
m 25 would have been gone completely.
Is that what it looks like today?
Pretty close. Pretty close.
There's like a hundred years later,
there's still no trees. Yeah. And,
and if you've got, you're
looking at, I've parked there,
you're looking at the black and whites
that were taken in the early 19 hundreds.
Yeah. Which, which revealed the
extent of this, uh, of this damage.
So it's just stupid of us not to
pay a bit more attention to this,
especially when we have the
tech to actually do something
about it. We have that,
that nature though, when it comes to
climate debt, there's a curious denial.
There's a denial, um, of
the role of capitalism's in
the human story. And there,
there is even a word for that in, in
science and it's called uniformitarianism.
And,
and this is a particular philosophy of
science where the view is that everything
is, we see it in the world today
is how things have always been.
So if we don't see cataclysms today and
they're not playing a major part in our
story today,
then there weren't cataclysms.
And they didn't play a major part in
our story in the past. That's why,
although it's before the
time of human beings,
when the evidence that the dinosaurs
were made extinct by a comet or an
asteroid, a first came out,
um, Lewis and Walter Alvarez,
the father son team who were behind
that science were ridiculed by their
colleagues and they were told him,
absolutely observed. Of course,
no cosmic event could have
made the dinosaurs extinct.
They spent 10 years taking that ridicule
until they found the crater in the Gulf
of Mexico.
Since then,
the whole scientific community has
accepted that the course of life on this
planet was radically changed
by a cosmic impact. Um,
you know,
I like to joke about it,
but it was a cosmic impact that was big
enough literally to turn dinosaurs into
chickens because that's what's left
of the time. So align is, you know,
the birds,
and at the same time,
skulking in those primeval forests is
this little mammal and it looks a bit like
a shrew,
a 65 million years ago going nowhere.
The dinosaurs ruled the earth.
Then the cosmos intervenes.
The dinosaurs are swept out of the way.
And what happens,
the mammals start to evolve very rapidly
and they start to occupy niches that
were previously closed to them. And the
bottom line is we would not be here.
The human species would not be here.
We would not be having this conversation
if the dinosaurs had not been made
extinct 65 million years ago. Uh,
so these are, we'll changing events.
And my argument is that such a wheelchair
in event occurred between twelve
thousand eight hundred and eleven
thousand six hundred years ago,
and it's high time.
We paid more attention to it.